bello i robot grande sarà un gioco della
madonna col robot farà tutto d'azione
horror incredibili e siamo in diretta
ciao ciao skipper mi presento max max o
ma ciao e come già sapete coinvolgere le
barbie deficienze centro trovatelli
delle sorelle robert centro trovatelli
dello sorelle roberts quindi non
indugiamo oltre e andiamo a dare
un'occhiata
andiamo a dare un'occhiata se avevate
ogni piccolo charlie anch'io chelsea no
non devi dargli da mangiare quello
quello sempre per infilarlo su per il
culo a oggi ciao ragazzi vi sia una vera
campionessa colpe b guardate mi chiamano
vera non avevo dubbi guarda bravissima
spero vi sia piaciuta questa breve
indirizzata dietro c'è il canone dico
che sono contento perché la rifacciamo
ma non prima di aver soccorso il
piccolino pronte non ho sentito i could
no poi come si va negli hotel a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti questo video sono
famiglie oggi siamo sul videogame modulo
che barbie barbie nelle sue sorelle
salvataggio e cuccioli
non lo so perché mi eccitava la sigla
nel caso vi steste chiedendo perché
farisei fai questo gioco di mezzi no
questo gioco bello per sesso femminile
che tutti i videogiochi vanno apprezzati
quindi cercheremo di trovare le qualità
di questo videogame miscredenti iniziamo
a giocare sta roba perché ancora non ho
capito il senso fatecela bicicletta di
una bambina di tre anni nove partite
uscire dal gioco una pratica posso
iniziare a giocare unify scrivere anche
il codice fiscale di tua madre pene duro
per i loro nome della barbie penso sia
per nessuno allora ragazzi io non so i
comandi questo potrebbe essere un
problema
allora non è una tattica di rimorchio
che funziona zio te lo garantisco questo
tentava all ingro paggio per strada però
devo andare a salvare i cui tagliate
dalle pene che devo salvare i cuccioli
tagli ti uomo birillo farà anche
l'acrobazia e tv gta vai no niente
acrobatica mille direzioni
stai andando a [ __ ] zia è cosa leggi
cava sempre con queste michia di
smartphone luridi che i miei più sono
molto affanno ma qual è un cane vero
farmi che piacere vederla signore no
quello è un cane barbie è un cane un
cane hanno messo la foto di un cane vero
c'è neanche farlo in digitale un cane
vero cose che vuoi ancora dalla vita mia
ciao mi metto subito all'opera e barry e
appena ascoltato un dildo giganti in
centro città se vuoi utilizzarlo prima
che lo facciano gli altri ti conviene
darti una mossa l'hanno visto dove farò
ritorno prima che tu possa dire beh mica
mi stava facendo il telefono
comunque ragazzi credo che sia la bici
più scattante dell'anno c'è meraviglioso
ma quanto è bello andare i fischi
e questa la canzone ma che cazzo eccoci
a il volantino è posto un cane vero
fatemi uscire come si scende a gunner
che cos'è un cane killer quello si è
cagato addosso perché c'era il tombino
da un'ora e mezza di sotto intanto di
trovare un cane 1 questo cane dai come
fai a non saper entrare
finché non riusciva entrare in sala bici
di mezzo il cucciolo deve scarico da
qualche parte di classe in sherlock
holmes
veramente non ho idea di come tu faccia
essere così intelligente ho trovato ci
siamo ragazzi ce l'ho ce l'ho
dov'è dove vado suicidarmi sì che bello
anno devo andare laggiù non c'è il
rampino non siamo in splinter cell
maledizione se fossi stato in gt avrei
usato un cacciabombardiere per arrivare
dall'altra parte della casa invece devo
farmela a piedi come i cristiani che
scandalo sto gioco è uno scandalo
ragazzi soliti dalla strada neanche un
po di sangue per arrivare al cane c'è la
tristezza ma dove è l'azione due sono i
gangster narcotrafficanti grazie per
avermi salvato il cucciolo barbie sembra
così dolce voglio morire dove lo london
non c'è nessun cucciolo dove l'hai visto
ho trovato ma dove attirare gunner fuori
dal suo nascondiglio ma dov'è usa le
frecce per soddisfare le esigenze del
cucciolo so io cosa vuol fare il
cucciolo altro esigente questo caso che
siano anche i bambini non c'è nulla da
temere
esatto è che faccia chi ci ha lo vuole
lo vuole per prendere il cucciolo e
nicchia che bello che soddisfazione
quando ho finito un blog fornero
contento uguale porta gandara al canile
sulla bicicletta si portiamo rai
si no ci siamo schiacciati contro un
cane o siamo morti entrambi
ragazzi siamo arrivati a casa con la
bici tra tutti contenti il fatto che
macchina già stati per la macchina
gliela in video sembra un paziente
davvero felice gli ho fatto vedere le
palle non nel senso alle per la palla
tieni premuti e interpreta sinistra per
strada il bacino che cazzo di
combinazioni di tasti e enter p destra
per la ragazza
i nomi che questi ragazzi progaming c'è
una sfida vera mi sento provato
ricompensa 10 ossa grazie controllare lo
stato di galliano è carino è bello ma
per me può anche morire fa bar che sei
diventato un call center tu sei stata la
quelli con ali barbie la riconosco
sporcacciona per usare la macchina noah
in abc dai cazzo cioè una macchina della
madonna non la voglio la bce dire ciò il
mio bambino al mio bambino un cane è un
calcio di clone che piacere vederla
signore stiamo parlando di cani non di
bambini né di signori cani mortacci suoi
mai visto un cane invitato ad ora c'è
una macchina della madonna perché non si
può guidarlo ma allora la vedi questa è
una macchina ce l'hai e tua lei
parcheggiata davanti perché usi quella
merda di bici qualcuno mi rubi la
macchina almeno lo so qualcuno la
sfrutti allora io quasano tipo call
center quindi posso fare cose trailer
del film cos'è il trailer del film
un tesoro perduto nel tempo una nuova
avventura cuccioli adorabili
i cani i cani che cercano il tesoro se i
cani bardi e le sorelle in barbie e il
tesoro dei con bardi e tua sorella
disponibile in dvd a partire dal
prossimo autunno che fino a torino con
gli occhietti o con la lente
d'ingrandimento come sherlock rega e
sanno avvenire emorroidi
ve lo dico è bello ma no grazie perché
apprezzo è porta gand ok ci siamo
portiamo sto minchia di care a forza
allenamento addestramento che non ho
capito se deve diventare un power ranger
mio comando il cane o madonna progaming
slow motion papa è addirittura questi
effetti incredibili ma come potete usare
questi effetti nel 2015 bella bravissimo
sinistra
ok timone d'oro non è un percorso
semplice cioè penso che veramente debba
essere un cane cibernetico non so come
faccia come cammino io quando mia madre
mi dice che il pavimento bagnato ci
siamo grande hai guadagnato altra 10
ossa ancoras 80 ossa e fai uno scheletro
comunque ragazzi la tua e letteratura
dei cani è sempre stato il mio lavoro
c'è ho sempre desiderato forza cosa
comunque mi chiama rocco siffredi
ciao barbie se trovi il mio cucciolo ti
ricompenserà con una bombata a casa mia
un cucciolo smarrita la mappa mi torna
utile
rimarrai ad occhi aperti nel vedere il
mio pene lungo due metri e ragazzi devo
farvi a cercare questo cucciolo perché
ovviamente ha bisogno di
aiuto è che dove stoccare farvi capire
come internet un big come sono entrato
in un tombino in stata per cui dalle
tasche fuori dalle fognature
probabilmente devo devo guidare il mio
cane all uscita che io non è questo
aspetto non proprio ora che è board da
puoi farmi fare una strada più corta
malizia sarò qua mezz'ora per dare la
mia vita velocizziamo pure dai dai dai
sì i soldi la scala che se in camion ai
le braccia sali la scala un'altra
questione è stato cosa lo mettono nella
bici che siamo qua ragazzi non ce la
posso fare mai una deficiente e una
deficiente gante che salva ricucci e
stabilire lo scanner ci dirà tutto mi
chiamo esce fuori che ci alle boe a e
vernet e rio microchip scegliendo un
nome che gli si addica un nome che sia
dica al cane è ovvio chiamiamolo rex ma
ci siamo ragazzi problema non è come
chiamare il cane è per te però ovvio non
piangere cucciolino risolveremo turno no
ma sto piangendo per il nome che gli ho
dato non per il dente devo fare il
dentista su bar di pensionati è
diventato barbie passione dentista
siamo ragazzi ho pulito i denti ai cani
nella mia vita non ho mai desiderato di
meglio lo giuro basta non ne posso più
va bene possibile di mortacci tua
ragazzi concluso vile episodio perchè
giuro mi sto sforzando non ce la posso
più fare e orribile maschio chance casa
è bello è bello anche solo un po di
tutto però è bello per tutto quello che
non c'è quindi ragazzi sono ogni tanto
viene da fare ste cagate ma devo farlo
perché è più forte di me va bene
lasciate un like per il coraggio perché
non tutti sanno questo coraggio anzi chi
è che gioca bacchi che sono compra io
però ai video sia piaciuto a casa che
doveva piaciuto se commetto è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
nei video tra tante iscrizioni ai corsi
di sky poi ci mettiamo proseguito è
bella ragazzi e ricordatevi che barbie
di osserva sempre e vi ruba i cani
va beh questa è un'altra di bella
ragazza